how's it going to go Rick I can't even
say brother wow what a great intro help
let's just play it off hey hey
you welcome back to Stanley parable
how you doing thanks Ari or a woman when
Stanley came in a set of two open doors
he entered the door on his left all
right we have a lot of stuff less to
play okay well I highly recommend you
watch your first episode otherwise you
have no idea what the [ __ ] is going on
probably you would have no idea what the
[ __ ] is going on even if you don't watch
it hard to see web snow last time I went
in the right door and [ __ ] you know what
let's let's just cut to where they are
all right we're back at the elevator
things done it I think perhaps we've
gotten off on the wrong foot here well I
know what you're their friend you really
are no I realize that in valuing your
trust in someone else can be difficult
but the fact is that the story has been
about nothing but you all this time
there's someone you've been neglecting
Stanley someone you've forgotten about
Jesus please stop trying to make every
decision by yourself I know that one
prosody what I'm asking for
know that one prostitute [ __ ] how does
he know about that now just joke alright
last time we jump down there I'm
pointing at the screen thinking that you
can see it as is it's done that's my
level of your chance to redeem yourself
to put your work aside to let her back
into your life she's been waiting it was
a one-time thing okay
geez so we have joke
I should not just roll over there all
right I've seen you before in Mirror's
Edge I think I've seen you before in
half live I've seen you before and God
why okay
cigarette Vince why so many buy so many
I asked I don't want to go in here Stark
is scary what the [ __ ]
Walsh AB blood that's her standing you
need to be the one to do this watch of
reach out to home if you can truly place
your faith in another then pick up the
phone oh [ __ ] console later hello hello
[ __ ] phone isn't working is that you
watch hold on sweetie sorry to keep you
waiting I'm just pulling the bread out
of the oven alright okay there we go
alright now I want you to come in and
tell me all about your do it's a fake
come on
did you actually think you had a loving
wife they want to commit their life to
you what I'm trying to point here
Stanley I'm trying to get you to see
something what's wrong go inside let me
show you what's really going on here man
she's beautiful this is a very bad story
about the death of a man named Stanley
oh shut up you good morning press J on
you [ __ ] you you know I have my wife I
have my
reg I'm fine god damn it gunshot later
you just had to tell him did you could
never trust you I knew your tits weren't
real what a boring fellow Shanna has a
job that demands nothing of him [ __ ] you
man every button that he pushes is a
reminder of the inconsequential nature
of his existence well what about this
girl
she's pretty consequential don't you
think look she even has like fake
trousers it's great and a ball head who
doesn't have a woman with a ball head
are you doing I I can think of at least
three people look at him they're pushing
buttons doing exactly it was told to do
now he's pushing a button now he's
eating lunch oh he's going home no he's
coming back to work one might even feel
sorry for him except that he's chosen
this life hey I love this wife I love my
wife I love my kids that I don't have
and I love this pain I love that
microwave I know Arthur's head but it is
mine it is mine he can go on fantastic
adventure how far from behind his desk
Stanley dreamed of wild expeditions into
the unknown fantastic discoveries or new
lamb I can I discover wonderful and each
day that he returned to work was a
reminder that none of it would ever
happen to him watch it but I don't have
I have a TV and so he can't decide about
his own job first he imagined that one
day while at work he stepped up from his
desk to realize that all of his
co-workers his boss everyone in the
building had suddenly vanished off the
face of the earth no the thought excited
him and terribly excited me terribly
spend time with the boys the hell does
that even mean
don't please me game don't you die
should I press I don't know yes sir yes
he went further he imagined that he came
to end open doors and that he could go
through either a shed last choice it
barely even mattered what lady
each door the mere thought that his
decisions would mean something was
almost too wonderful to behold prepare
dinner
but at barababa as he wandered through
this fantasy world he began to fill it
with many possible smiles and
destinations down one pathway an
enormous round room with monitors and
mind controls and down another was a
yellow line that weaved in many
directions and down another was a game
with a baby
no no I tell your kids a story it was
such a wonderful fantasy and so in his
head he relived it again and then again
and again over and over
wishing beyond hope that it would never
end that he might always feel this free
surely there's an answer down some new
path mustn't happy yeah perhaps if he
played just one more time oh but there
is no how could there possibly ow in
reality of all he's doing is pushing the
same buttons he always has nothing has
changed because Ben's here the more
invested he gets the more he forgets
which life is the real one got a sleeper
and I'm trying to tell him this that in
this world he can never be anything but
an observer that as long as he remains
here he's slowly killing himself but he
won't listen to me
he won't stop here watch this Stanley
the next time the screen asks you to
push a button do not do it the
temptation that's the powerful must
resist
this is the trap isn't it
nothing's gonna happen until I click it
unless I quit the game ah [ __ ] me you
see can he just not hear me it's fine I
tell him in a way that he'll understand
that in every second he remains here
he's electing to kill himself how can I
get him to see what I see how can I make
him look at himself question nothing in
the way I wanted
I simply played my intended purpose the
same as Stanley we're not so different I
suppose yes now I'll try once more to
convey him this to him I'm compelled to
I must perhaps well maybe this time
you'll see
well well with maybe that's the cause
him and I tried again and Stanley pushed
a button and I tried again and Stanley
pushed a button what a night I didn't
click anything what don't you dare
jump-scare me
no now well that ending was kinda
[ __ ] gay I can't wait to tell this
story to my coworkers Stanley thought
how am using they'll find it oh won't we
all just laugh and laugh at the time I
thought everyone had gone missing
alright let's go to another place
Stanley walked through the red dirt
reminisce hey I want to see what happens
when you walk through the right door
because we didn't do it so thank God you
are willing to listen to me I guess see
that I really have wanted you to be
happy all this time the problem is all
these choices yeah the two of us always
trying to get somewhere that isn't here
running and running and running just the
way you're doing right now yeah don't
you see that it's killing us Stanley
no I just I wanted to stop I would we
would both be happier if we're just
stopped okay fine think well I think I
have a
Ellucian yeah let me show you there's a
chef both the door opens I hate
decisions all right that one's black
this one is black black it is it is all
right what you got what did i do what
did I do
mmm what do we want what are we looking
for
I don't know oh yes if we just stay
right here right in this moment with
this place Stanley I think no wait where
are you going this place is pretty cool
oh no stay away from those stairs if you
hurt yourself if you die the game will
reset we'll lose all of this how will I
get home Stanley let me stay here hey
don't take this from me what what I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna [ __ ] do it
I'm gonna do it and if you don't tell me
to stop I warm that's a great man once
then we think about what you're doing
what I'm gonna jump down that's what I'm
gonna do as a great man once said no
actually let me rephrase that
as a [ __ ] just said Yolo
I'm fine oh I'm fine thank God
I broke my legs you have me worried
there for him out no can we please get
back to the earth
are you in sorry sorry about that one
hey hey let me just get back to the
speck watch ah there now see this is
what happened this is where we can both
be hey man if you stop moving
we just have to stop them
that's nice
but now
but what if what if we go back out
Stanley go back there's nothing good
that can come from this but I love
jumping it's so much fun and with that
let's do it again
[ __ ] let's do it again no no what do
you do you just not believe me
what can I say to convince you I don't
know but it was fun
I want to jump again look me I'll do it
360 this time Yolo Wow let's go back to
the other room now
can you do that for me now my god is
this really how much you dislike my game
now but you'll throw yourself from this
platform over and over to be rid of it
you were literally willing to kill
yourself to keep me from being happy
am I really yeah yes maybe you're just
getting a kick out of it I don't know
anymore
I just wanted us to get it along well
you need to try harder I guess that was
too much - I know you're dense like you
wanted to make a choice after all well
this one is yours my eyes my dafuq is it
over it's going to restart isn't it I'm
going back and that was another ending
of Stanley the Stanley parable so if you
have if you wanna play another inning
leave a like tell me what you want in
the comments and I'll see you in the
next 1000
a belly a little bit afternoon drazi so
I feel I can see missing it
take it back if that's the kind of mind
[ __ ] we're talking about here